If you want to hear the truth about the gamer
girl bathwater AIDS scandal, then stick around
to the end of this video.
[intro]
Hello, and welcome to another exciting lesson
here on Horror History.
My name is Light Yagami, and today we’re
going to be looking at one of Pennywise’s
most trusted allies, a so called gamer girl
with ties to Satan, whose publicity stunts
and money making schemes have taken the internet
by storm on multiple occasions; who has battled
massive entities like Mark Zuckerberg, The
Brighton Police Department and PewDiePie;
and whose bravery and valiant efforts saved
the life of a hamster one time -- I am of
course referring to Belle Delphine.
In order to understand how she came to be,
we’ve got to start at the beginning, so
let’s take it back to the birth of Belle.
[HORROR HISTORY]
Mary-Belle Kirschner was born on October 23rd,
1999 in Cape Town, South Africa.
She was born with a dislocated hip that required
extensive surgery, which likely saved her
from a life confined to a wheelchair and gave
her the ability to do this.
🎵 All Star - Smash Mouth 🎵
Kirschner’s father was Caucasian man who
married multiracial Japanese woman and by
the time of their daughter’s birth, they
were living in South Africa.
The Japanese heritage of Belle’s mother
likely had a large impact on her interests
culturally, because she’s known for her
anime-style cosplays which include anime and
Japanese video game characters, and perhaps
her most notable pose in these photographs,
is her ahegao faces, which are a staple of
Japanese Hentai.
She’s also been known to sketch illustrations
of manga and Japanese video game characters.
Her mother’s influence on her life may have
stretched further than that though, in an
Instagram Q&A, Belle revealed that her mother
has taken some work as a model, and that this
experience made her mom more accepting of
her career choice.
I wouldn’t be surprised if this worked both
ways and Mrs. Kirschner’s early modeling
work helped inspire some of Belle’s thottery.
As a young girl, Belle spent a lot of time
exploring outdoors and loved hiking mountain
areas and beaches, so when she moved to Brighton
in the United Kingdom and didn’t have easy
access to these scenic areas in nature, she
took to the internet to entertain herself.
It was here that Belle would realize the power
of the internet, but she did not yet know
of the extent at which the world wide web
would alter the course of her life.
Belle showed the wit, intelligence, and creativity
that she would later use to build a $500,000
business early on in her school days, where
she was constantly at the top of her class
in nearly every subject with the exception
of English, and if her Patreon page is any
indication, she hasn’t been able to improve
her English skills in the years that would
follow.
Screenshooting is not a word, there’s a
comma missing after ‘hamsters’, there
should not be a comma here and that’s the
worst use of an apostrophe I’ve ever seen.
“You’re my king and you’re helping me
unbelievable, thank you so so much.”
It is possible that the grammatical
errors on her Patreon are part of the Lolita
aspect of her character, but I’ll get back
to that when we get there.
First, Belle would demonstrate her drive to
be successful and make money by beginning
her first job at the age of 13, and she worked
many jobs from a young age, including being
a barista, a dishwasher and a waitress among
others.
I find it interesting that waitress was among
the jobs that she held, even at the young
age of 13, because it’s one of the few professions
in English culture where an employee who plays
their cards right can typically make a few
extra pounds from customer tipping.
“In England, where I’m from tipping
is seen as optional.”
I wouldn’t be surprised if she picked up
a few tips and tricks, pun definitely intended,
that she could use to make some extra money
in another tip-friendly venture of hers down
the line, her Premium Snapchat.
The year following her 14th birthday in 2013
was a life changing one.
She dropped out of school, started her own
Facebook page which she named “tinkersmell”,
which she would use to share selfies of herself
and friends online, and started a relationship
with a girl named Hannah.
The relationship with Hannah, along with the
fact that she’d abandoned her education,
may have been a contributing factor to her
leaving home a year later at the age of 15
to move into a shared household.
It was here that she started her first Instagram
account and on March 27th, 2015, she would
make her debut on the gram, which would eventually
become her most successful social media account.
This also marked an aesthetic change, which
featured most goth looking photographs with
piercings and fake tattoos -- she seemed to
be heavily influenced by the style of alternative
pop artist Melanie Martinez.
Belle’s relationship with Hannah would go
on another year after that, but when Belle
was 16 it was over.
It was also around this time that the stage
name “Belle Delphine” was adopted and
she began to make a more conscious effort
to brand herself in a specific way.
I think this was the most important moment
in her career: the moment that Mary-Belle
Kirschner died, and Belle Delphine was born.
This was more than just a name change, this
was the creation of a character, and the portrayal
of this wacky character is the reason that
she is successful today.
Belle realized that on social media, your
most valuable asset is the attention of your
audience, and having an outlandish character,
an exaggerated extension of oneself, is an
effective way to garner that attention.
Combine that with the increasingly revealing
outfits in her posts, and Belle Delphine had
a recipe for success, but it would take some
time before her first big breakthrough.
In the meantime, she took up babysitting.
Now I don’t know what parents took a look
at Belle Delphine and decided, “you know
what?
I think we should hire her to look after our
baby.”
I mean roll the clip.
“And here is my lovely doll.
So I actually put my actual human hair.
I’ve also got some baby arms.
And some baby legs.”
But to be fair, that clip wasn’t online
at the time she was babysitting.
She started her YouTube channel on July 30th
2016 and in August she would post her only
video of that year, a makeup tutorial that
seems to be nothing more than a makeup tutorial
that would bring in 90K views through it’s
first two years.
“Hi, I’m Belle and today I’m
gonna be doing my everyday eye makeup for
you.”
But like great character actor YouTubers like
Daxflame and MirandaSings before her, I think
she realized that she had to start off a little
bit normal and show us that descent into the
occasionally morbid kawaii e-girl that we know
her as today.
She used some of her babysitting money to
fund a van tour through France, I guess she
was a few years early on the whole #vanlife
trend…
I mean I can only imagine how successful her
“How I Shower in a Van” video would
have been, considering the demographic of
her audience.
In October of 2017, about one week before
her 18th birthday, Belle would undergo a curious
procedure that would physically change her
appearance forever, and be the subject of
countless conspiracy theories and speculation.
In the photo...
is that a plane?
**** that's a plane
In the photos leading up to October 17th,
2017, two things are apparent.
First, she’s really leaning into to the
innocent, child-like aspect of her character
by posing with toys and wearing shirts that
say “baby girl” or “daddy’s girl”.
And second, she seems to have perfect teeth,
at least the top row doesn’t look like it
needs any work, which made it very curious
when she posted a photo wearing braces, which
she supposedly got for free, not sure why,
but this led to a lot of speculation about
her motives.
She was only one week from turning 18, and
I think the braces were a stunt to revitalize
her lolita image as she moved into adulthood.
She has, on multiple occasions, used the lolita
culture as part of her character, in one video
wearing a lolita shirt.
“I’ve also got my lolita book.”
And it just seems like she feels that’s
an important part of the character, because
despite marketing herself as an adult symbol,
she never technically crosses into adult content,
instead opting to do memes and just straight
up weird stuff, like the whole thing is really
more of a satire act than anything, even if
that’s not what some of her paid Patrons
are probably there for.
[heavy breathing cat]
But I think that’s kind of what makes the
next two years of her story so funny, is that
there’s just like this sharp contrast between
what she claims to be and what she’s actually
doing, because immediately after getting the
free braces, she starts posting the ahegao
photos, and if you’re not familiar with
Japanese culture, ahegao is basically this
trope that’s seen a lot in Hentai, or adult-only
manga, used to denote a woman who is feeling
extreme pleasure.
So this becomes Belle’s new money maker,
and I’m not talking about Monopoly money
because in March of 2018, she would open a
Patreon, where she would allow the internet’s
thirstiest gamers, and most desperate YouTubers,
to donate money or pay a monthly fee for lewd
photos, and for 25 dollars, these incels could
gain access to her entire collection of Ahegao
content.
The account had over 1,000 Patrons within
6 months, and with the average pledge up around
$6.70 at the time, Belle was probably earning
over $7,000 / month on Patreon alone, and
that’s before you factor in large one time
donations, like the $2,500 that WillNE paid
her to make a video to help him in his subscriber
battle with Morgz Mum,
“Tonight!”
Please turn that off -- and the 3 grand that
Pyrocynical donated in hopes that Belle would
play Fortnite with him.
Nice cover story Pyro.
“Rise up people.
We need to stop Morgz Mum.”
RISE UP GAMERS!
--But between her now booming Instagram, her
lucrative Patreon and her exploding Tik-Tok
that earned her a spot on roughly 75% of all
Tik-Tok compilation thumbnails on YouTube,
Belle Delphine had officially reached meme
status with the most popular Belle Delphine
memes being this Ahegao one and her take on
Nyannyancosplay’s truly transcendent Tik-Tok
dance, Hit or Miss.
“Hit or miss, I guess they never
miss, huh.
You’ve got a boyfriend I bet he doesn’t
kiss ya.”
Yeah.
Truly, truly an artist of our time… kill
me.
In September 2018, Belle would finally come
out with her second YouTube video, and in
typical e-thot fashion, it's a room tour.
So, in typical member of the male species
fashion, I'm gonna roll it.
Ok and I thought Sofia Coppola knew how to
start off a movie when she made Lost in Translation.
I'm kidding, I'm kidding.
I'M KIDDIN--
But the room tour is a great example of what
makes Belle as interesting as she is.
The majority of her room is overwhelming cutesy
and kawaii, which just makes it ten times
better when she reveals her wall of animal
skulls, the paddle, masochistic treatment
of teddy bears and collection of firearms.
"It's a really weird designed house but, excuse the gun".
OK.
I'm suddenly regretting memeing on her now.
At least she's over in the the UK, it's not
like you can get a gun into the US right?
Before the year's end, Belle would find herself
in the news after a fake article titled: 'Judge
Orders Premium Snapchat Model to Pay $60k
in Taxes to IRS After Multiple Reports by
Internet Users' was released and although
the website, Huzlers.com, is known for its
satire articles, the general public did not
know that and the story picked up a fair amount
of traction.
And I think seeing this buzz over her in the
media gave Belle an idea, a lightbulb went
off in her head despite this hilarious comment,
and it helped her form a new PR strategy going
forward in 2019, which would be her craziest
year ever.
She kicked it off with an appearance on the
then biggest channel on YouTube by posting
a dance to the PewDiePie’s famous T-Series
diss track, which he then reacted to and…
obviously… used her image in the thumbnail
for those gamer views.
“Thank you Belle Delphine, very cool.
Now I can use her in the thumbnail for millions
of extra views.
Thank you Belle Delphine.
This is a blessing.
She would spend most of the first five months
of the year planning and creating a library
of content.
Remember how I said she has to start with
something relatively tame, but slowly descend
into madness?
Well on June 14th, she reached the bottom
of that descent when she uploaded her third
YouTube video titled “meet my best friend.”
Oh OK, this is nice, she’s just making some
manga sketches with her friend… she’s
actually pretty good -- OH-KAY it’s a dead
octopus with googly eyes.
And she’s touching it.
And it’s touching her food.
And it’s getting all over her bath… (more
on that later)
OK, not going to lie, I’m kind of jealous.
Two days later, she joined Twitter so that
she could broadcast to a wider audience than
those just following her Patreon, but it would
be Instagram, her biggest platform with over
4 million followers where she would make her next
big announcement.
On June 16, 2019, she posted a photo with
the caption: “If this video gets 1 MILLION
likes I’ll actually make a hub account.
The time has officially come.
Tag Ur friends / dad to help you.”
To which the Hub themselves, were ecstatic,
and so was the internet, so four days later,
the photo had reached one million likes and
Belle stayed true to her word and created
an account on the hub.
She would upload a total of 12 videos, which
I will show… after the break.
I’m not going to repeat the titles of Belle
Delphine’s uploads on The Hub, but, as promised,
I will show you some footage of the clickbait
videos she posted there.
Like this one, where she plays with a pair
of large chickens, this one where a mysterious
hand helps her cook… kind of… and complete
an iDubbbz meme.
“I have osteoporosis.”
Or this one where she… squirts a water gun
while wearing a squirtle shirt.
If you didn’t believe what I said about
her being more of a performance artist than
an actual adult model, I think these 12 videos
will set the record straight.
There’s even one where she just simply eats
a burger on camera, a reference to a famous
video that artist Andy Warhol made in 1982
where he does just that.
Roll it.
OK, that’s enough, stop rolling it.
OK, seriously.
Stop rolling it.
STOOOOPPP
Yeah, despite her Hub content having no actual
graphic content, some of her audience seemed
to have no issue with that, but the videos
were majority downvoted, even the one where
she eats a picture of PewDiePie, which got
her another reaction from him on that week’s
episode of LWIAY.
“PewDiePie does all the way inside
Belle Delphine.
Marzia: Pizza time stop--”
The videos on the Hub would bring in between
300K and 3.6M views at the time of recording,
and more importantly, it got a lot of people
talking about Belle Delphine, however, there
would be one unintended side effect.
Later that month, the hand of Mark Zuckerberg
taketh away, and Instagram struck down her
account.
This had a deep emotional toll on the 19 year
old social media star.
Actually, I made that up.
Why the **** am I even making this video?
But her next big business venture, which would
become her biggest business venture, was right
around the corner.
On July 3rd, 2019, Belle Delphine announced
on Twitter: “I am now selling my bath water!
this is what humanity has come to :) get yours
here...www.belledelphinestore.com”.
The bathwater, which went for $30 at the time
sold out in under 8 hours.
People paid money, to acquire water…
I can’t.
I really can’t.
And you can’t blame Belle for taking advantage
of a business opportunity… but who are these
people?
How desperate do you have to be?
So after the bathwater sold out, a number
of things happened.
First, she became a meme.
Again.
Everyone was making bathwater videos, some
real, some fake, some drinking the gamer girl
bathwater, my friends Mr. Creepypasta and
Vincent Vena Cava even did a creepypasta narration
video about it.
“You should have seen her.
Pink hair.
The tightest little body, those eyes… those
big round anime eyes.
She was like a Hentai drawing come to life.”
Then the accusations started coming out.
A headline was posted to Twitter from an account
posing as the British newspaper, Daily Mail,
which said “Over 50 People Have Reportedly
Contracted Herpes After Drinking Instagram
Star Belle Delphine’s Bathwater.”
Like the fake IRS scandal, some people believed
it, and rumors once again spread, and for
a couple days there it seemed like a fact,
and most of us were wondering if she was gonna
get sued.
And there were actually multiple fake reports
floating around after that.
“And then over the last few days
the ‘news’ broke, and I’m saying ‘news’
because it’s not a real thing, but it broke
that ‘1 person sent to hospital after drinking
internet personality’s bathwater.’”
Some people started to figure out that this
was a hoax on July 9th when fact-checking
website snopes.com verified the information
as false, also citing subsequent tweets from
the Twitter account that started it.
“Between July 7 and July 9, @BakeRises intermittently
tracked how their hoax tweet had caused the
number of their followers to explode, while
another tweet explicitly stated that “It
seems the best way to grow on Twitter is to
impersonate a company and say things about
a celebrity that legally can be considered
libel and I could potentially be sued for.”
And have wiser words really ever been spoken?
…. Don’t answer that.
The next day Belle cleared everything up when
she officially made a statement putting the
rumors to rest, but I do have to commend her
on the decision to wait one week before
doing so and take all the free press.
She may have gotten the idea for selling bathwater
from the Matt Greoning show, Disenchantment,
where a man known as the decrepit peddler,
has a similar business.
“Me flavored water, fifteen cents!
Come taste my knees.
Fifteen cents!”
This could be a coincidence, but I’m thinking
it’s not, because in one of her photos,
she’s wearing a T-shirt referencing a segment
from Matt Groening’s previous show, Futurama.
"Popular.
Sl*t Club.”
“Oh my God!
There’s Jake Finkleberg.
He’s so hot!
I wish he wasn’t my brother!”
“Popular.
Sl*t Club.”]
*Laughter*.
That always makes me laugh.
I love Futurama.
Also, I think Belle Delphine could do an awesome
cosplay of Princess Tiabeanie from Disenchantment.
They somehow just kind of look alike.
Eventually, the bathwater came back into stock
at a much higher price point, along with the
$50 gamer girl chewed gum and they $10,000
gamer girl pee.
She actually felt the need to put the disclaimer:
“this is not for drinking.”
*deep breath*
So even as the bathwater thing… evaporated…
Belle continued to gain notoriety when Ethan
Klein came up with a new disgusting product
idea on his weekly show: The H3 Podcast.
“So what I was proposing to her is
that if you will make a tier award.
Call it Ethan Tier.
Above God.
And the reward is, I will fart in a mason
jar and mail it to you.
So Ms. Delphine, if we want to call her that,
decided to send Ethan a mystery box, which
he received on July 21st and opened on the
podcast.
“Hello H3H3.
I hope you got my little box.
And no it’s not my dirty socks.
It’s a little weird, I must admit.
But I sent you a bottle of my own ____….
Oh it’s a poem!”
It’s not what you’re thinking.
Ethan and Hila received a jar full of gamer
girl spit along with a flash drive containing
the proof that this is actually her spit.
Oh, and a hat.
Honestly, it’s a pretty nice hat.
The podcast netted 1 million views and the
VOD added another 1.6M. Guess who was featured
on the thumbnails.
It wasn’t Jason Blum.
So that’s basically the peak, I mean there
was this thing in late July or early August
where she supposedly was hospitalized while
vacationing in Greece, but who knows if that
actually even happened, but at least she looks
hot in the photo.
Then there was October 7th, where she claimed
to have been arrested, and went on to explain,
“I swear this girl came to my party and
stole my hamster.
I have no idea why, or who the frick does
that?
I spray painted the heck out of her car and
got arrested, at least I got my hamster back.”
Not too many big YouTubers fell for it this
time, but if enough small YouTubers talk about
it, she can still get a decent amount of attention
from it, and that’s exactly what happened.
She’s now in a never-ending cycle of outrageous
PR moves, which are boosted by thirsty gamer
boys talking about it, which leads to another
outrageous PR move.
Her net worth is reportedly over 500 grand
and she continues to post weird stuff and
grow her ever expanding fanbase.
So that concludes today’s lesson on Horror
History, if you didn’t drop out like Belle
Delphine did then your assignment is to like
this video and let me know in the comments
who I should cover on the next Horror History.
If you want to see my analysis of other horror
characters then click that playlist on the
left.
Remember to subscribe to CZsWorld for new
horrors every week, ring that deathbelle Delphine
for notifications and I’ll see you in the
next one.
And if you’re wondering why I did a Horror
History on an e-thot, you might want to check
the date of this upload.
Assuming we both survive.